[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
before i start wanting to praise allah
subhanallah talah the most merciful the
most just or praise the glory and
gratitude belongs to him
in my country they say a saying the
following
the one whose stomach is full will never
understand the one that's
hungry brothers and sisters for yes
maybe a decade maybe over a decade we
had an individual called tommy robinson
who has actively been vilifying
muslims on a daily basis on the social
media platforms on the news on the media
wherever it may be
until i myself confronted him with the
permission of tala
and exposed some of his lies and flaws
so
all he was doing brothers and sisters
was what looking at people
who are coming from war zones and
have had their lives destroyed their
family members killed
their children's lives at risk and they
have gone to the extent
of jumping on boats yeah makeshift boats
with god knows how many number of people
going down the channel from dover to
the uk and other means etc to get to a
safe place to live
and what they're called they want to
take over they want to maim kill us rape
us
you know all this kind of stuff that was
coming out his mouth
now if you guys remember in the
beginning of the video i said
the one that has a full stomach stomach
will never understand the one that's
hungry
so tommy robinson lives in a nice lavish
house jacuzzi
his kids go to maybe private schools or
whatever you know is he's
you know well established because of all
the lies and he's been spreading
now right now the tides have turned
and it's very important for us to
understand this brothers and sisters
allah can change the condition of one
person instantly
that's why personally if i have any time
in industry perform advise anybody
be on the youtube platform etc i never
ever ever
look down at them that i feel like i'm
better than them and that they can never
change i always envision and imagine to
myself just to keep myself humble
and level-headed that i don't feel
arrogant that that very person who's
sinning right now he might be better
than me in 10 years time in 20 years
time
why do i do that because brothers and
sisters allah
will teach you a lesson if you are
arrogant if you are self-righteous
and think you know you you're getting a
piety attack
with tommy robinson he came to find this
the hard way
now in this video which we're going to
react to by the way
in this video he let's listen let's
listen with
together each other let's listen i was
due to be coming back for a
demonstration on saturday
there's something i haven't told
everyone i had a incident
quite a few weeks ago with an arson um i
do have the video of everything
but it was targeted against um i do have
the video of everything
but it was targeted against against my
property i'm not against my property
against my wife's property
um at that point we left the country
straight away
and i'm looking at relocating my family
which is pretty hard to do
obviously my wife has had enough of
everything
um someone gave us somewhere to stay so
we left so
wife is under pressure there's been an
attack that's happened which is
uncalled for i totally am against
violence of any shape
or form especially to an innocent family
i made that very clear when he was
spreading himself lies
by jeopardize his family which is an
absolute lie yeah so
his wife is putting pressure what about
all those immigrants those people who
are living in these war zones where
bombs are being dropped
left right center starvation and the
the wife is saying you know what we need
to get out of here and the husband is
finding means to go to a safe haven
you're in that very situation now tommy
robinson so we left the country
and i was treated to be flying back for
the demonstration obviously
now with this 14 day quarantine if i fly
back i probably won't get back out my
kids are out here
i'm still in the process of finding the
permanent relocation from i've got new
schools for my daughters
but that's just an update look at me
look at that
oh mate so because my family away
because i need my family to be away
because they're
not safe basically and it wasn't muslims
that done this
um it was after all the blm stuff okay
i think the talk blm black lives matter
movement yeah so it's very clear that
somebody like tommy robinson has been
pushing constantly muslims
you know they want to kill us in 120
verses of the quran he says
all this kind of stuff and he is living
leaving
the uk because of muslims no
because of who he says he claims black
lives matter yeah
well i don't know the full story etc but
what's very certain and clear
is that certain remarks he may have made
that might be racist or whatever
has put himself in danger and his family
in danger which is very careless let's
finish off the video
so guys you saw for yourself and
subhanallah it's
it's crazy now he needs to relocate to
somewhere else and imagine he goes to
spain
and imagine in spain they tell him you
know what we don't want you here
now something along those lines did
happen in this very video that you're
going to see
tommy robinson was spotted and this
video was sent to me i'll be honest with
you guys yeah i have my differences with
this guy tommy robinson
a lot and i've dealt with it and i've
closed that chapter it's done and dusted
yeah but in this very video he
is being approached by someone insulting
him in front of his family members which
i found very disturbing
i'll be honest with you guys if i was
there what he was saying to tommy
robinson is a whole different story
but insulting his family and kids
uncouth i'm so sorry i don't care who it
is
it was absolutely disgusting no family
or children or kids
should deserve to see that very
situation feeling hostile don't know who
this person is
it's a very very distressing situation
and i'll make it clear it was very
unquote for but just one thing i want
tommy robinson to understand
the hate that you call the people that
muslim families
who are out on the streets or in
restaurants in certain places in the uk
which i've lived i've lived in certain
very racist place
yeah and i've been my family have been
under attack yeah i used to live in a
place called grimsby yeah i used to live
there
and i my family got under attackers of
racism
before i was a muslim and imagine the
family members the muslim family members
who are sitting in a restaurant and
eating and a
hooligan a scumbag comes and and this
happened
actually in australia this up in
australia actually a pregnant muslim
woman was
punched and you are the cause of that
they don't just justify i'm not saying
that you deserve that
i'm just saying look how does it feel it
doesn't feel right and it shouldn't be
done
to anyone so i hope brothers and sisters
we heard we learned a lesson from this
that we'll never ever look down at
anyone because god almighty the one who
created the heavens and the earth can
change your situation
to such an extent that you are now a
refugee
an immigrant looking for a safe haven
for you and your family
brothers and sisters till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh